[Musique]
à la pharmacie
béatrice remarque qu'on recherche une
caissière à temps partiel l'emploi
parfait pour moi se dit elle le
lendemain elle reçoit un appel du gérant
avant même d'être reçu en entrevue
béatrice doit remplir un formulaire dans
lequel on lui demande son numéro
d'assurance sociale et l'autorisation de
faire une enquête de crédit
béatrice trouve qu'il est un peu tôt
pour se dévoiler autant son malaise est
il justifié oui selon la commission
d'accès à l'information du québec
un employeur ne devrait pas exiger le
numéro d'assurance sociale à l'étape de
la pré embauche
ce numéro sera nécessaire seulement si
l'entreprise engage béatrice cantal
enquête de crédit
l'entreprise doit démontrer qu'il s'agit
d'une exigence essentielle à l'emploi et
le fait qu'une caissière manipule de
l'argent ne rend pas essentiel une
enquête de crédit
d'ailleurs une telle enquête pourrait
même être considéré comme de la
discrimination
le fin mot de l'histoire pour
renseignements personnels ne sont pas
faits pour être se met à tout vent